[Music]
today's question comes from david in
pennsylvania i would like to purchase a
small house my neighbor who's a realtor
says i have to have a credit score to
get a mortgage i'm 18 years old and i'm
not too sure what to do i was inspired
by you not to get a credit card so i use
debit cards or pay with cash do i need
to establish a credit score to buy a
home the age-old question
well this one's easy because i did it
without a credit score so there we go
personal testimony real life proof you
are a home owner
and you did not pay cash you got a
mortgage we got a mortgage and you did
it without credit score and we did it
with no score wait a minute are you real
we're not real you're not real you're
performance of your imagination this is
the funniest part dave we get this a lot
and we we talk about manual underwriting
we talk about no score loans of course
our friends at churchill mortgage do
these all day long but for some reason
people go it's so much work oh my gosh
you can't imagine how much work it is to
to get a no score loan
what did you have to do i literally had
to look up maybe three utility payments
i had to pick up maybe a few extra w-2s
and hit an upload button and i went okay
wow that was a lot of work
they didn't they didn't even verify your
employment i mean sure they they do the
basics but there was nothing crazy where
i went home you had to sign a piece of
paper saying they could email us or
check with us sure yeah they usually do
a voe a verification of employment yes
and a vod the verification the deposit
at your bank make sure you have the
money yes and a w-2 and a couple of
utility bills i don't know how you got
through all that sounds stressful
it took 17 years for us to get the
mortgage dave it was really it was not
that big of a deal i almost wanted it to
be a bigger deal because people made it
out to be this big deal
and so uh david to answer your question
you do not need to establish a credit
score unless you want to play
play the game of the system and you're
already doing great you're you're paying
with cash you're using a debit card so
here's my advice is to you know go with
someone like a churchill mortgage who
does a no score loan manual underwriting
they call it a few different things and
here's what i would tell you get a
healthy down payment you're 18 years old
you're super young and he's looking into
getting a mortgage and the biggest thing
is to get that healthy down payment
where they go oh this guy's got money
he's got a job he pays his bills on time
we're going to give him a mortgage
that's how they did in the olden days
yeah back in the day before before fico
took over the world
uh
all right so here's the first thing
it's okay if you don't buy a house when
you're 18.
as a matter of fact it's
probably better than okay
if you just take let's take your time
you're alright the second thing is
a real estate agent that does not know
about manual underwriting that you can
buy a home without
a credit score is not a credible
real estate agent this is not someone
that you would use they do not know what
the crap they're doing
so don't use your neighbor
the real estate agent yeah incompetent
and if they if they are saying ah we
can't do that it's probably because they
just don't want to go through the hassle
no it's because they don't know how yeah
which means they're ignorant and you
don't need to buy a house from them
that's what it means
and so it's a pretty simple formula
in that regard